remember that the mitt romney fella that
nobody really liked well his nobody
likes me tour continues months after the
election he went on fox news sunday with
chris matthews and he brought his wife
who makes him apparently more human
let's take a look but it was not just
the campaign spot i believe it was the
media's fault as well is that he was not
giving being given a fair shake that
people weren't allowed to really see him
for who he was all right what about the
media I'm happy to point the media the
media because clearly were so likable me
in this fake man uh what do you think
like it's months later guys and they're
still like like I never understand this
idea of like well they wouldn't let MIT
me beam it like wasn't he was supposed
to run the country so he couldn't run
his own campaign running for president
you're gonna have all those people
running you around MIT yeah I'm you just
he just has to stop it already I want
them to go away I desperately want them
to just go away have and they're still
trying to like what how does not light
right well you know toke it up baby see
will give them an interview or whatever
but after that then what no no here's my
girl they've gotta go grace as
gracefully as you can at this point just
and the irony of them talking her
talking about fair and balanced media
and given the interviewed of fox news I
don't know what I was lost on her or
what ah but I agree that I mean
everybody blames the media you know
that's the first they're the first
targets but I actually felt like the
media was more prominent very I feel the
same way I feel like they were very
generous with him and kept giving him
time and time again to get better at
what he was doing and he just never got
a better well you know the guy you know
he was hiding money in the Cayman
Islands the forty-seven percent thing
like all of this stuff met be admit that
was myth being MIT so when they let when
he was himself people were going I
really don't like this guy but but the
idea that he's not running his campaign
is the scary part to me like how are you
gonna run the content can chat if we had
on your can we have the guy in men in
black like unzipped is human suna was a
giant
it's like I felt like it was gonna be
that moment where he skin falls off and
he's just yeah some so I'm gonna go back
to the part where he was a homeless man
getting a gas remember that the photos
are lies that's far more interesting to
me than watching him on fox news yeah
out in the wild like that remember that
old photo of him looking homeless it was
like a two or three two or three days
after the election was that night I
think yes pumping his own gas at some
random guest and his hair was like the
other way for the first time Armand I
would have voted for him so that I would
have voted for ya I can't relate to him
the other pump my gas looking home
wasn't pumping gas overnight that's not
that well I guess we have consensus here
then that nobody's gonna be on a sitcom
Everybody Loves MIT is that fair to say
i think that's yeah what about everybody
hates me everybody hates me which is
similar my already hating cares about me
i really think that's what I didn't care
but it was me so I don't know yet it's
worth listening to be the mother or his
mother to be on that show I'm
auditioning for that to you guys what am
i just being a little kind about it i
preciate bonobos calm is the official
outfitter of the Ruben report enter code
Ruben report for twenty percent off your
next purchase